well captain's reporting for duty while
Entertainment Weekly has broken some of
the first image I guess really the first
official images of Captain Marvel don't
know when we're gonna get a trailer how
much you want to bet it it happens while
I'm like doing other stuff and I can't I
can't
dude turn around a video right away but
so we've got our first official look at
stuff it's so weird to me that
Entertainment Weekly still breaks a lot
of this stuff sometimes it's still
strange to me but anything is we got a
good look at the full costume cuz we the
images had come out before but it was
very obvious that there were a lot of
after-effects that hadn't been done on
yet because you know there was a lot of
green on it there's no green on that
outfit so I was like that's green-screen
they're doing something else and this
outfit it's it's funny it it doesn't
look in the still image as if there's
any sort of effect there that would
require green-screen but I would imagine
that anything that is like that is
probably not going to show up too much
in a still image like if there is a glow
effect if like there's any kind of a
ripple if the bread's you know shifter
or anything along those lines who knows
that's not you know really gonna show up
in a still image so but it looks good
it's pretty dang comic accurate which I
always appreciate I still kind of wish
they've done that even shorter
you know cropped really kind of tight
you kind of uh stylish but feeling a
little bit more military cut that that
Carol Danvers sometimes has in the
comics for the hair that they've got are
having it still looks pretty good I dig
it
we got a look at a few other things too
so we got a shot of a number of
characters and from behind we get what
does indeed look like Ronan the accuser
and I had to double-check because this
did get announced but I had forgotten
that Ronan the accuser and Korath the
pursuer are both
gonna be appearing in this since it does
take place before the events of
guardians the Galaxy ie before they both
got killed so that'll be interesting
I'll be curious to see if that is just a
cameo or if there's more to it than that
I can't imagine it's gonna be all that
much because the main focus of this is
said to be on the scrolls which we also
get a first look at now the scrolls are
something that again I have a feeling
probably doesn't benefit too much from a
still image so the look that we get
again pretty dang comic accurate they
got the green they got you know the sort
of weird wrinkles and shapes and skin
it's looking pretty good
but you know it looks like it looks like
heavy prosthetics and you know it looks
it looks like high-end Star Trek it is
what it does but again I would the
nature of the scrolls and their whole
shape-shifting thing I think odds are
we're gonna see them like that the
minority of the time and even when we do
that's probably gonna be frequently
shifting into other things so I suspect
that the full impact that look of the
scrolls is really gonna be impossible to
judge until we see it emotion probably
in a trailer in fact I would bet a
second trailer because I will bet you
the teaser is mostly gonna focus on her
and not who she's fighting so I don't
think we're gonna get a good look at
like what the scrolls are really gonna
look and feel like for a while yet but
we are getting our our first glimpse of
them and they look like they stepped out
of comics which I'm totally down for
that I I do like in general that Marvel
is really embracing the you know the
looks from the comics you know there's a
little adaptation going on here and
there but by and large they're very
clearly using what's in the comics as a
template not as oh god do we really have
to do it like that they really seem to
be celebrating it which is something I
appreciate and pretty much all these
movies so I don't have a ton more to to
talk about because there's only so much
I'm willing to extrapolate
based off a couple of still images but
what I see so far
I like I dig it it looks neat
and I'll be I'll be very curious to see
a trailer when we get around to them
because the the big thing I want to get
a sense of is the feel and the vibe of
the thing and that's that's more or less
my big question mark at this point is
what is the what is the sub genre within
superheroes that it's going to fall
under I mean obviously eventually it's
gonna be you know kind of the kind of
the space adventure sort of thing but if
we're dealing with the Scrolls well the
thing that would be most mostly
earthbound dealing with infiltrators
that we have so you know that we have
among us so I wonder if we'll get like a
cross between sort of espionage and and
alien adventure I don't know but I this
is a project I'm really curious about
and I really hope they get right
if for no other reason than we really
need some more franchises for female
superheroes besides Wonder Woman I don't
mean that like you know some sort of
demand for equality I mean like if for
no other reason than just to take the
pressure off the next Wonder Woman
because one of them weirdest things that
went on in the wake of the first Wonder
Woman movie was the very awkward post
release discussion you know with people
saying well no you can't say anything
bad about it because it's it's all we've
gotten we have to praise it and then you
know other people you know saying well
it wasn't feminist enough or it wasn't
this or wasn't that being you know I did
a whole other video on this but it's
just what happens when there's you know
50 movies worth of expectations being
heaped on that because there have been
there had been 50 male led superhero
films since you know a lecture and
Catwoman had happened before we got
Wonder Woman so that carried the weight
of about 50 films and just so that we're
not putting undue burden onto the one
female superhero franchise that's
currently going I hope this does well so
that we can you know stop over
scrutinize each instance and just take
them and enjoy them that's the reason I
want more female superheroes so that not
Sun not every one of them has to be a
standard-bearer when you're the only one
you are by default the standard bearer
as their become more other films will be
allowed to do other things and that's
that I want that freedom so those are my
thoughts on Captain Marvel first looks
that we've had looks good I'm hopeful
keeping my eye out what a trailer drops
I will get on as quickly as I possibly
can what do you think about what you've
seen so far whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's a whole
bunch of stuff to do there's buttons and
there's links one of them goes to my
patreon and there's all sorts of things
down there so why don't you take a look
at those click away if you feel like it
and remember folks you're the council I
just run the meetings then until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]